Tim do you think we're seeing a massive
change here in the in the establishments
idea of Israel it's a very difficult
thing to answer because first of all I
don't think our relationship has ever
been unquestioning I can recall during
the last Israeli operation there was
word out cabinet that David Miliband I
think has said where does all this end
if you go way back to 1973 much of
Europe actually abandoned Israel are
quite shamefully during that conflict as
I I think there's always been a question
it's just that when it comes to the
crunch the issue is what does the
British government say about a situation
which many people feel angry about and
aggrieved about but for which there is
no alternative at all on the table and
this is what I think whilst he was
trying to express it's notable that she
has not offered a single alternative
policy no one has no one can
Cameron hasn't even though he's
expressed his frustration Miliband
hasn't Clegg hasn't the reason is very
simply because Israel is defending
itself it has a legitimate right to do
that but in the course of doing that it
is unfortunately and I believe without
intend to do so killing innocent
civilians now what does what is Britain
supposed to say to Israel stop in which
case is Israel really supposed to suffer
all those rocket attacks or is it
supposed to say go ahead which I think
the public and much of the International
world of regard as outrageous especially
when you know you at the UN school are
being targeted and children are being
killed so I I don't think it's not
unquestioning um I think people want to
have a discussion the problem is no
one's quite sure what to say because
there really is no alternative I think
the best response is the one has come
from well-being I try to write about
this too which is my own personal
religious and Christian response which
is to say let's dress humanitarian aid
and it's trying to help them to work the
way out of it and let's let's pray about
this to me just that simple sense of
wanting to show compassion for a truly
tragic situation is the only thing one
can say right now because there are I
have no practical or not going off
practical alternative which is the world
the international community the
government in this country unites in
recognizing the constant cause of these
constant wars is Hamas and that Hamas
must be defeated and that Qatar must be
stopped from supporting Hamas and that
other countries in the region we support
him as and they are dwindling must be
stopped from supporting Hamas and that
Hamas itself must be destroyed that is
the only way to stop the 18 month to 2
year endless repetitive cycle of this
conflict it will be done not by berating
Israel not by grandstanding against
Israel it will only be done by defeating
Hamas I think everyone would agree with
that if as part of that that the
economic situation of Gaza's improves
because a lot of people recognize that
Hamas it's not a legitimate expression
of the very difficult circumstances that
garson's lying themselves hang on it's
not that it's not the worst living
conditions in the world and there are
far worse living conditions far worse
GDP and so on the problem is I would
come back to this that in 2006 and 2007
when the world saw having been voted in
by the people of Gaza and you could take
the view that when people vote for
terrorist group there is if there is you
know some culpability on them but even
if you don't take that view and I don't
particularly you could have taken the
view and the international community did
not
but once Hamas then used that
post-election period to carry out a coup
and to kill the fat our opponents of
theirs and to make sure that they got
the situation they now have which is
that they never have another election
that the international community could
have moved in it could have decided to
intervene it could have toppled Hamas at
that point it could have used regional
leverage to get rid of Hamas and instead
what we are seeing in each cycle of this
and we're seeing it with it is that
gradually the international community
and so-called do-gooders in the West are
actually taking part in the process of
pushing the Palestinian cause and
Palestinian needs and desires for right
into the same bucket as that of Hamas
and what this means is that we are
pushing the Palestinians and Hamas into
the same pot that is I think a disaster
because
that way you actually cannot get a
solution to the israeli-palestinian
dispute because Israel cannot make a
deal with Hamas I think you're
absolutely right and it's a very good
observation that particularly in terms
of media coverage there's been a slow
misunderstanding of the relationship we
know mas an ordinary Gazans and I think
people through this narrative of Israel
indiscriminately killing people are
indeed validating that Hamas narrative I
turn it around slightly by saying the
Israeli state does not necessarily speak
for all Israelis and conversely much of
the media gives the impression that
there is universal Israeli support for
what's going on and there isn't but it
never is it is a very very high majority
of the approval ratings for this
operation are in the 80% plus of the
Israeli public because 80% of the
Israeli public are under rocket fire and
they don't like it any more than people
in London would like it